I'm not talking about slight changes to  your body because you had kids I'm  talking about women that let themselves  get obese  obese  and I'm not talking about men that leave  the secondary women's gains at least  stop a little bit of weight I'm talking  about men  that tell their wives or feel like they  can't tell their wives okay that they're  gaining weight and they're not sexually  attracted to them anymore that's an  important part of a marriage  so yeah men have the same right that  women do  they can leave for whatever reason they  want I don't think you should stay with  someone you're not sexually attracted to  I think you should communicate to them  first your problems  and you know I think in some instances  you say for the kids because it's better  for the kids to be together you know